joined on the couch for a new segment
we're going to be talking with some
Scott Butterworth matt s Pinelli these
are two of our big deus ex fans in the
office and Scott you recently got the
chance to try out deus ex mankind
divided this is our first time getting
hands-on yeah you had a big preview but
overall what was your what was your
experience with it uh uh I guess my
experience was basically if you've
played human Revolution do you you
pretty much know what to expect out of
mankind divided it very much feels like
they are expanding on and iterating on
the ideas established in human
Revolution and just more refining them
than reinventing them the mechanics and
feel very familiar to people who played
that game and of course anybody who's
played any of the day sexy ins really
but there was there was new stuff to try
out there were things that a time to try
you were in this yeah level four for
three hours yeah wasn't so yeah if
anybody read the feature that went on
that went up on the site last Thursday
that was a completely true headline the
way that a lot of these preview events
work I mean they were nice enough to
bring us up to itís Montreal to play in
the studio and generally in those types
of situations they have a very specific
portion of the game that they are
allowing us to play this is the part
that's not buggy the sock in a crash
that they've sort of like polished a
little bit so you can play it before the
game is actually done so generally those
sections are relatively sure they're
just to give you a taste and an idea of
what the game's going to be like and so
typically because of sections of short
the amount of time you get to play them
is you know also short because they'd
expect you to get through it relatively
quickly that was not the case in
Montreal interestingly they kind of just
let me loose on this level and we're
like yeah like you've got like three or
four hours you just kind of play around
do it everyone so I just kept playing
through it over and over and try
different things every time obviously
one of the big hooks for people who may
not be familiar with the games you can
kind of approach them in a variety of
ways I mean the two major obvious ways
to do at our geno straight combat or
straight stealth it is completely
possible to play through any day except
deus ex game without killing anybody
with the exception of boss battles which
we will get to but it's also possible to
play through like it's a traditional
first-person shooter and just shoot and
kill everyone and blow things up and
just kind of run for it but it's
quite like a like a hit man style
stealth different paths to choose kind
of game correct yeah so that was what
was interesting about getting so much
time to play the game I really was able
to explore all of the different options
and all the different potential
approaches that you could take you know
one of the things I talked about in the
future that I think is really unique to
the deus ex series is just how detailed
and dense the level design is I mean
it's designed in a way to support all of
these different potential play styles
the sort of tortured metaphor that I
that I use to explain this not in the
text but when I was speaking with the
developers was it's each level is kind
of like a piece of rope and stick with
me because this is a little torture that
I realize it's horrible but so piece of
rope has a beginning and an end right
that there's a start there's an end it
can rope in any number of directions
right but a rope really is a variety of
threads all spun together wound together
to create this cohesive single unit
right so the level design and day sex is
very much the same thing there's you
know you start at one part of the level
you need to get to another part of the
level but the number of paths you can
take in between and the number of
different approaches are incredibly
extensive to the point that even after
three hours I was talking to other
people who had played the same portion
and learning things that I didn't
discover in that amount of time which is
pretty crazy because it was not a very
long mission so the fact that I was
playing it for three hours and still
didn't see everything is like kind of
just incredible so that was yeah that
was my hands on experience with the game
so mad you didn't get to play mankind
divided but you have played a lot of the
series as a whole going into it are
Yemeni concerns that you you're really
hoping that they they address with the
sequel well for one thing one of my
major concerns would have to be the
enemy AI that was more a hugely kind of
criticized factor of human Revolution so
I was actually kind of curious for Scott
yeah from your experiences how was that
yeah you know we were actually talking
about this a little earlier today in the
office and I would say that it's
probably a little too early to make you
know a full ruling on exact
we how good the AI is I mean that's
that's it that's something that
generally gets tweaked right up into
launch it's something that can be
improved or changed with relative ease
um and that's it I had both good and bad
experiences with the AI like for example
there was one mission i was playing
through in just entirely stealth and had
the tranquilizer sniper rifle and was
hiding an event and shot a guard and
somebody sort of behind him notice that
he collapsed and crumpled to the ground
and so he came walking over to
investigate and as he's you know stopped
and stood over the you know lifeless
body of his friend I sniped him and then
he fell asleep and fell down and
somebody else noticed that this happened
and he wandered over and eventually
there were like three or four guys in a
dog pile of just like all asleep on top
of each other i'm honored stealth games
which is like not how that would go in
real life um but yeah i think there's an
interesting point to be made there that
maybe that's not so much a product of
poor AI as much as it's just like how
stealth mechanics and games frequently
work i mean you could do the exact same
thing in most Metal Gear games or
Splinter Cell Games and that's just kind
of a byproduct of stealth in games the
way it works mechanically but that sort
of stuck out to me as an interesting
experience with the AI but then on the
flip side of that coin i think the AI
also demonstrated some uh really there
was a really intelligent moments um when
I went in guns blazing they would
frequently either you know flank to get
a better position I mean which is pretty
standard but also I thought was
interesting they would retreat if I was
doing well like they would actually move
further back in the level and find cover
and get away from me if I had already
killed other members of you know other
teammates of theirs so I thought that
was actually pretty impressive that they
reacted that well instead of just
rushing at me and letting me shoot them
one by one and i will say that don't go
in guns blazing in this game you will
die you will run out of ammo and you
will die it's very much meant to be a
cover based game and I think that really
stems from the fact that it is a very
cerebral and strategic experience it's
not meant to be you know it just Duke
Nukem style blow everything up
experience you really need to assess the
battlefield use the environment to your
to your advantage
very tactically move among the various
obstacles that you can use for cover so
that was yeah again the AI I think was
uh was pretty impressive but I don't
recommend running at them Matt when you
were playing these games how did you
typically approach the problems you
would come up against um usually by
stealth uh though I'd love to kind of
make use of a hybrid between the two
everyone's and well just kind of play
the cat and mouse game that was always
my preference did you actually Scott did
you ever kind of utilize cuz I know you
did like a combat sort of approach and
stuff yeah did you ever use a mix
between them at all interestingly so I
mean the way that it would typically
work in the game is you can choose your
upgrades as you're playing right i mean
there's an extensive progression system
it is an RPG at its core but because we
were playing a game or a mission from
the middle of the game they just created
some preset loadouts for us and there
was a stealth mode out a combat load up
but then also a balanced load out that
kind of gave you a little bit of both um
so yeah if you if you want to play that
way you absolutely can actually won one
way that I you know one method I used
basically relied on exploration more
than anything and I think that that
would actually service a nice balance
between stealth and combat because you
can kind of utilize either one depending
on what you come up against as you
explore the level but I actually managed
to make it pretty much to the end of the
mission without encountering anybody
simply by skirting the edge of the level
and finding a wall that I could bust
through to get into the back of this
theater I was trying to infiltrate so
again it the game does a pretty
impressive job of allowing for any play
style that you can come up with
including sort of a balance between
stealth and combat coming up on the end
of the stage did you get to go into a
boss battle did you see how those
mechanics not although I was able to
talk about that with the developers like
I said so the segment that I played was
relatively short it was clearly intended
to you know allow me to get my hands on
the the mechanics of the game just the
core gameplay I was not indicative of
the overall experience I mean I saw very
little of the story very little of the
social aspect of the game and also did
play any boss battles but I am well
aware that that is the biggest single
issue that people had with human
Revolution so I talked about that
extensively with the developers as well
as the endings if for people who didn't
play the pre
his game most people were not happy with
the way that they handled sort of the
choices at the end of the game in a sort
of mass effect 3 kind of way I'll try
not to spoil anything but suffice to say
the developers were well aware of
everyone's concern and in fact they
themselves even knew at the time they
weren't completely satisfied with the
way that those those aspects of the game
turned out but even just from building
them they they learned even before they
got any reaction from from the audience
they knew what didn't work about in what
they needed to change and hopefully we
will see those improvements come alive
in mankind divided and we're also going
to get to hear more about these things I
mean you had a very extensive preview up
on the site but there's some more stuff
that we're going to be coming that's
going to be going out of that yeah so
the preview that I put up last week was
purely a hands-on focused you know is
talking about my experience playing the
game I'm also working on a feature
that's going to be very interview driven
it's going to be a lot of my discussion
with the developers I was able to sit
down with five different members of the
core creative team discussed basically
every aspect of the game's design so it
gets a little heady but there's a lot of
really interesting information about
their stuff about you know Adam Denton's
progression the way this ties into the
overarching mythos of deus ex a lot of
sort of deeper material that I think
people will be very interested to read
and Matt I guess are our last question
is is there anything that you want to
know from from scotter that you really
hope that they change her that they fix
about the games you just make this an
overall better experience well Miss
Moore not so much a serious thing though
I kind of wondered myself if there's
going to be a new sort of replacement
for the classic but also kind of cringe
worthy I never asked for this man that
seriously like that that line is the the
cake is a lie Deus Ex just the most so I
don't know who knows I mean like I said
unfortunately I got very little exposure
to the story or two the dialogue didn't
get to meet Elias effects as the the
voice actor maybe someday I believe that
there's a gamespot interview with him
somewhere from back in the day but I
didn't get to talk to him unfortunately
so it's entirely possible there will be
some new meme that emerges from this
game but as of yet we have not seen it
so someday well one of the
places you'll be able to find that I was
probably going to be here on gamespot
and we'll be looking to you Scott Matt
thanks so much for talking about the
game and I look forward to hearing more
what you guys think about it as as it
comes along so deus ex mankind divided
is due out februari 23rd 2016 so we have
a few more previews left before we see
the final game but thanks so much for
watching